la nuit tombe dans le grand est africain
trois français sont livrés à eux mêmes
sans eau depuis plus de deux heures
perdues au milieu de la savane
à la recherche de l'amour
[Musique]
oh vous êtes là non non et non
mais on n'est pas au cours la
place qui manque le plus c'est la ses
deux lola je donnerai cher pour boire de
l'eau mais la donne une bouteille je
bois un litre d'eau tranquillement
alors je trouve ça y est les lèvres
sèches aussi la pierre je fais d'ici là
on est dans la survie dans le stage de
survie parce que ça n'était pas prévu ça
c'était pas prévu comme de plus en plus
de penser ils ont choisi ce type de
vacances un peu particulière tester
leurs limites se battre contre la faim
ces stages de survie ont le vent en
poupe
un retour à l'état sauvage qu'il ne
pensait pas être si dur quelques
semaines plus tôt
l' aventure commence dans la campagne
picarde
cet homme qui courent c'est josé armando
dans quelques jours il va participer à
un stage de survie avec huit autres
personnes alors depuis un mois ils
s'entraînent sans relâche
quoi s'attendre
on garnit trajet sera une clé culte et
sur le dénivelé
avoir
pour être en forme
il a payé 2000 euros pour le plein de
sensations fortes
alors j'ose et sa femme ont suivi les
recommandations de l'organisateur à la
lettre il a dû acheter toute une liste
de matériels
il ya bien sûr les indispensables
comme le sac de couchage le tapis de sol
ou les chaussures de randonnée mais pas
de traces de produits d'hygiène de base
je peux me laver les dents et du savon
coin
bio bah oui
mais certains vêtements surprennent un
peu josé
d'un côté bonnets et gants et de l'autre
en maillot de bain alors du coup je me
suis fait une déduction est ce qu'on va
droit dans un pays qui va être chaud la
journée et froid le soir d'où l'intérêt
d'avoir le goût bleu bonnet gants ou
alors peut-être que denis nous attristée
pour brouiller les pistes et là pour me
mettre c'est vrai non encore plus dans
le dans le doute en fait car la petite
particularité de ce stage de survie
c'est qu'aucun participant ne connaît la
destination
il ne la prendront que quelques minutes
avant le départ
[Musique]
une semaine plus tard baril
nous retrouvons josé fraîchement arrivé
de picardie avec sa petite famille
c'est enfin le moment pour lui de
rencontrer ses futurs compagnons
[Musique]
à josé mais celui qu'ils attendent tous
ces sept hommes de neil organisateurs
car avec lui leur ai besoin de connaître
la destination de l'instance
et pour leur annoncer donné leur montre
une série de photographies avec des
indices sur la destination à eux de
devenir
c'est parti
je reste avec vous avez le pays non
c'est un drapeau mais
non
non pas d'attendre
on y voit la
tanzanie on va là où les touristes vont
pas bien certes avertit tout de suite
savez l'afrique noire façon
paléolithique
la
direction l'afrique à plus de 15000
kilomètres de la france
en tanzanie au pied du kilimandjaro
loin des zones touristiques des parcs
nationaux à 500 kilomètres à l'ouest
dans une zone désertique pratiquement
inhabité le territoire d'une tribu qui
vit en corse en contact avec la
civilisation les hadzabés
après trois heures de marche en pleine
savane le chef de la tribu vient à leur
rencontre
bonjour
bienvenue sur le territoire de la tribu
hadzabés nous habitons à bas un peu plus
loin
j'ai démontré notre comprendre
l'impression
[Musique]
je pense et c'est que le début
et voici l'endroit où le groupe a passé
les six prochains jours
un amas rocheux ou les selles a pris
sont des grottes ils dormiront à même le
sol et pour survivre et si ils devront
éviter cette tribu qui vit là depuis des
milliers d'années
pour les aider denis prend en main les
premiers gestes il emmène un petit
groupe chercher de l'eau sans elle
impossible de survivre plus de deux
jours
en suivant les rivières asséchées ils
leur montrent toutes petit avoir des
sources mais pour l'instant aucune trace
qu à quelques centaines de mètres de là
d'autres sont partis à la chasse avec
les athlètes
[Musique]
pierre jose et jérémy sont en plein
travail louisa marque il s'apprête à
s'attaquer à l'animal le plus dangereux
des environs le babouin un singe
agressif aux dents acérées
à droite de la rue tu vois les derniers
mois il y en a six est
divisé en gothique où les hadzabés cours
de sommet en sommet
non
avec leur cri ils font fuir les babouins
et les pousse à se réfugier sur une
seule colline
devant les yeux ébahis des trois
français la stratégie d alsace et
fonctionne en cercle et la colonie de
valois ne peut plus bouger ne reste plus
qu'à attendre la nuit pour lancer la
chasse il faut plusieurs groupes et les
concentrent à l'endroit
l'heure de la chasse a sonné
en quelques minutes le crépuscule laisse
place à une nuit noire
si les hasards il se déplace à pas de
velours pour ne pas réveiller les
primates le bruit des trois compères
résonnent dans la montagne
mettant sur ses gardes l'inconnue des
barreaux
[Musique]
l'un des chasseurs tente de tirer le
débat - on s'inquiète sont déjà réfugiés
entre les recherches la chasse est
apportée au grand désarroi on peut
fatiha les c'est trop dangereux comme si
on peut tirer
ici comme je te dis qu'on aurait pu
le danger est trop grand les babouins
risque d'attaqué décision est prise
d'europe ont sèchement
trois heures à errer à travers la bouche
pierre jérémy et jausiers retrouve enfin
le groupe à bout de force et assoiffés
on a failli tuer parce qu'on a descendu
la montagne
dans l'hérault
une aventure mais surtout un échec car
ce soir ils ne mangeront rien et devront
se rationner en nous
mais même si les ventres sont vides tous
sont tout de même heureux de pouvoir ce
soir passer un peu de temps avec leurs
autres
si nous sommes heureux caen n'a besoin
de rien de plus que ce que la nature
nous offre
j'ai votre
wii on est très heureux
si tu le souhaites tu peux rester avec
nous tout le temps qu humain mais moi je
viendrai jamais avec toi au village je
suis libre ici
bonne ambiance qui ne va pas durer moins
car au lieu de l'être
les éléments se déchaînent
des trombes d'eau s'abattent sur le camp
et en quelques secondes donc le sol se
transforme à bout l'eau pénètre par
kilomètre
[Musique]
on se tire là
descendre
on descend dans la grotte ya une grosse
en dessous parce que là on va être
noyées et ses impacts
mourad khier partant des créneaux à
travers le bush et cherche un endroit où
se protéger
on voit qu'il ya pas de grosse dose sa
part restée ici on peut avoir trois
places
au sec pour la nuit
deux heures plus tard ils sont tout un
groupe à se réfugier dans la grotte le
campement a pris totalement les
croise les doigts pour que ça dure le
moins possible et qu'on puisse dormir
sec dormir déjà dormir ce serait pas mal
les visages se crispent et laisse
apparaître inquiétudes et fatigue
[Musique]
l'appui ne leur laissera qu'une heure de
répit
au petit matin les stigmates de la
tempête sont encore visibles sur le camp
et le moral des troupes est en berne et
pieds trempés
la vie était dure eu
un peu plus que ce que je pensais
ils ne sont pas au bout de leurs peines
car si le campement est dévasté leurs
ventres sont totalement vide depuis leur
arrivée en tanzanie
ils vont alors tout essayé pour tenter
de se nourrir
certains s'improvise chasseurs à l'arc
[Musique]
il organise des grandes battues à
travers la savane pour essayer de
trouver des racines
affamés le moindre tubercules et dévoré
sur place
il essaie même de poser des pièges pour
pêcher des poissons dans les mares gré
par la pluie après trois jours sans
viande il attrape leur premier animal en
voilà un petit poisson de 3 centimes
note
reprend des bouteilles ont fait 4 5 p
genre les rend fous
se rappeler que l'écriture ce soir
[Applaudissements]
sa friture jérémy n'en verra bien sûr
jamais la couleur
deux jours plus tard le groupe est en
grande difficulté
fatigué
sale et malgré leurs efforts le ventre
quasiment vide depuis quatre jours
dany 60 ans le plus âgé du groupe
n'arrive plus à tenir sur ses jambes
[Musique]
marc supporter ça
il a réussi son pari allé au bout de lui
même
comme les autres il peut maintenant
profiter une dernière fois de ce paysage
qu'il ne reverra sans doute jamais
savourer au coin du feu oui dernière
soirée pour se dire au revoir
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
dès demain ils rentreront en france
retrouver leur famille leur travail tous
partiront avec le sentiment de s'être
surpassé un stage de survie mais pas que
une expérience humaine qu'ils ne sont
pas prêts d'oublier